[Laughter]
no matter what he's gonna come for us
again oh I hate that doll
having a show like Chucky represent the
queer Community is incredibly important
and impactful for so many people
including myself I wish I had a show
like Chucky growing up what kind of
weight does that carry for you
I think it does carry a lot of weight
because it is a community that deserves
just such recognition and
um I was really happy I got to be part
of this show because there's a lot of
things that people can empathize with I
think the best parts of my day are when
I receive messages from people who have
told me how much the show's helped them
and how much they've felt seen and it's
just it's awesome how does them being
sent to a Catholic Reformatory school
really play into Devin and Jake's future
as a couple you know obviously the
Catholic school is kind of known for you
not really you know appreciating you
know people with the queer community so
obviously that will play a part in
season two and you know I I don't think
I can say much about what happens but
you know yeah no spoilers obviously our
relationship you know will be a little
bit you know have some have some
obstacles in there season two I know
your history
[Music]
it's just a dog
working alongside horror icons like
Devon Sawa and Jennifer Tilly must just
be such an incredible experience I've
watched them on my screens for so many
years Zach what do you love about
working with two icons like that
honestly when I first met them I was
Starstruck I was completely I didn't
know what to say are you as happy as you
make me
ah she's just so amazing to work with
and she keeps it like really like on set
you never know what's gonna happen
because she's always improvising and it
definitely keeps um interesting I feel
like I'm being like taught something
even though they're not gonna need
anything directly I just feel like you
know I'm listening I look at them and
I'm like okay I like that season one I'm
gonna say was Bloody fantastic see what
I did there so season two would you say
it's even darker and a little more
bloody than the first season yeah I
would say that I think everyone will be
excited and uh you know really excited
to see the new stuff we're gonna have
for season two it's gonna be a little
bit a little crazy
hi I'm Chucky
wanna pray I was
such a fan of season one what did it
feel like to get not only critical
Fanfare but from fans of this iconic
franchise singing your Praises it was
crazy I mean
um growing up Chucky's just always been
something that's been super popular and
it's just crazy to be on the show now
everybody has such positive opinions of
the show and it's been really good
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos